mom looks like my diarrhea medicine's
arrived
it's not funny if it's not true i don't
know what to believe with you
i'm not lying like so many people at the
beginning of the pandemic
i found myself moving in with my parents
once my new york city lease ended yeah
it was embarrassing but i know i was
lucky that i even had that as an option
but as an adult
living with your parents is different
especially when some have lost jobs and
some are working from home all the time
it's just like a lot of everyone being
on top of each other
i'm living with my parents and just when
i think things can't get more
complicated
this happened okay so my period has not
come
i just went out and bought like five
pregnancy tests i don't think you really
need to take that many let's do this
you see that two lines it just appears
that i am indeed pregnant
i'm pregnant live with my parents that's
gonna be funny
to tell the baby one day right
yes that's right i found out i was
pregnant and
i had to hide it from my roommates who
happened to be my parents
before we go into that let me backtrack
a little because as anyone knows
um to get pregnant in the traditional
sense you know it takes two to tango
and yes my tango partner was
my husband mike he also moved out when
our lease ended
and in with his in-laws the pregnancy
was it planned
well that's like debatable
because yeah i eventually wanted to get
pregnant
like in two years or something you know
post pandemic
post living with parents that was the
plan
let me just say that if you thought
there was a grace period after you
switch off contraceptive pills to
another method you're wrong take it from
me and
my belly there is no grace period anyway
so
my husband and i find out i'm pregnant
and we freak out
so we decide to wait to see if the
pregnancy is viable
now with any pregnancy most people
decide to wait to tell anybody until the
end of the first trimester
and that's because up to a quarter of
pregnancies end in miscarriage
and most miscarriages occur during the
first trimester
but also we needed some privacy which
was a lot easier
said than done alcohol it's a dead
giveaway
once you reach a certain age as a woman
and you refuse a drink
everyone around you is going to ask oh
what are you pregnant
yeah so i did not want to get that
question
my big problem was my parents are a big
fan of night caps
like every night and also afternoon
my family likes to drink so avoiding
alcohol
was a real challenge we go to kind of an
outdoor
socially distanced dinner at my cousins
and
my one cousin's making margaritas and
i'm being given a margarita so what do
we do
i pretend to sip the drink throughout
the night and my husband strategically
switches his drink
which is nearly empty with mine end of
night my husband is
drunk not blackout but gray so we
realized
that wasn't a method we could really
continue with so we developed
a second method of strategically only
drinking
canned beverages beers hard kombucha
ciders
so when my mom would offer me a drink i
take the cider i soon after
go to the bathroom dump it out put a
funnel in there and replace it with
something that looks similar so like
with the cider i would pour in some
apple juice that i had
hidden underneath the sink and then i
would drink that the rest of the night
although my mom was getting me my
favorite cider and so it felt
particularly bad
dumping it down feeding it to whatever
sewer people
live deep down there but the ruse was
a success there was a second telltale
sign of pregnancy
i had to cover up and that was weight
gain now not everyone gets that in the
first trimester
but i did fortunately that one was a
little easier
to just blame on the situation it's the
pandemic
yeah i ordered a bunch of jeans in a new
size and then that kind of ended the
conversation because you know no one's
going to inquire further because
that's rude vomiting is the third
telltale sign
aka morning sickness although i don't
know why it's named that unless you also
consider the night
and the afternoon the morning because
morning sickness occurs
all the time after a few weeks i find
myself vomiting so i have to
hide my frequent bathroom trips i
dramatically order a bunch of diarrhea
medication which i open in front of my
mom
mom looks like my diarrhea medicine's
arrived
and make a big deal of thank god my
diarrhea medicine is finally
here huh so that she knows there's a
reason
why i'm always in the bathroom and then
when i'm in the bathroom i'm either
playing a podcast or i put some water on
to kind of hide the wretching it was
horrible but it worked
after all that i'm pretty confident i'm
going to be able to make it the full 13
weeks with this ruse
lying keeping the secret i feel really
great about it
until i make this one really dumb
really huge mistake so one day in
particular i'm feeling very tired and
lazy which
is another pregnancy sign that i blame
on medication
i text my husband can you bring me that
pregnancy book
only i didn't just text my husband mike
i
texted a chain with mike and my mom
so he replies to me uh did you mean to
do that
i am horrified i want to cry
i have put so much time and work into
this
and i ruined it all with like a really
dumb
text i didn't even spell pregnancy
correctly
i didn't spell pregnancy correctly maybe
i can cover it up so i text
haha just kidding i meant producer book
because i am a producer so you know
maybe i don't know i don't know what a
producer book would be
but i texted that and i didn't feel like
that covered it so i'm like
you know okay it's there you have to
face what you've done you got to go talk
to your mother so i slink towards the
kitchen to just
come clean to my mom and i see that
she's standing there
with her back to me washing the dishes
her phone is behind her
sitting on the table it appears to be
untouched my adrenaline is pumping i
grab the phone i run to the bathroom
i find the text message chain delete
delete and then i come back out
quietly and i put the phone back exactly
where it was she doesn't notice i
breathe a sigh of relief
i had so sh her computer
her computer gets all the imessages from
her phone
so it's going to be there she's going to
open her computer see it and figure it
out
so i find her computer in her room i
take it out i again go to the bathroom
probably to engage in one she must
assume is another
bout of diarrhea and i attempt to delete
the messages only i don't have the
password to her laptop
i know i only have a certain number of
tries so i try
password birthday capital p
password anniversary you know it's not
working my sister's name
plus the year exclamation point it works
which also i'm like my sister's name not
my name but whatever it doesn't matter
i'm in the computer i find the messages
i can't figure out how to delete them
individually so i just delete everything
i just hope she thinks it's like an
update that wiped everything out
anyway i get off the computer flush the
toilet to cover my tracks and then i put
it back where it was
and then i'm like sarah you just got
she has an apple watch the text would
have gone there
and she's wearing the watch so i wait a
little bit
and then i walk over to her i don't know
if she would if she did see the text i
don't know if she'd come right out and
say it
so i start off by saying mom i've got to
come clean about something
and then i stop and i look at her like
giving her time to fill it in
if she saw the text maybe she would just
say you're pregnant or maybe more likely
she'd say something like
oh what pregnancy brain you forgot to do
something
but no silence she just looks at me
completely clueless
so i'm just like i spilled soda on your
duvet i'll get you a new one if it
doesn't come out but she's like
okay and she goes back to washing and
i'm like
i can't believe it i can't believe i
just got away with all that
but i have to be smarter and i have to
be more careful
and so i am so fast forward a few weeks
all right we're about to go find out if
what's inside me is a baby
my first trimester is about over baby
still looks healthy
baby exists i decide to tell my parents
i wait till they go to visit my sister
in another state you know my sister
my mom's password so we're doing a zoom
call
and i surprise her and i tell her
no really really
really no you're not kidding right no
it's real i'm not
it's real and i accidentally texted mike
and you on a text message chain
even if you had not deleted that
pregnancy thing i would never
i would not have thought anything were
you not suspicious at all from that
no she has no idea
my secret was safe it didn't come out
because she thinks i'm a total
lightweight with drinking
she wouldn't have thought twice if i had
refused alcohol also she said she just
thinks i go to the bathroom a lot so i
didn't even
need to make up a diarrhea excuse yeah
in retrospect i wish i hadn't
come up with that lie anyway a few
months later mike and i move into our
own place again we have our own
privacy and we tell the news to a wider
friend circle so we're not keeping any
secrets from anyone anymore
literally not anyone because you know
now like
you and everyone else on the internet
knows
so yeah i'm pregnant so that's it
now it's out there no more lies no more
deception no more lies about the
deceptions
and i can just be excited and that feels
really good i think i just got a kick
[Music]